we all love to measure our
accomplishments whether they're personal
professional or even athletic you like
to take stock of where you stand
and if you're truly the best at
something
you might just set a record
most of us we love when a good record is
broken
you know that can trigger a heated
debate like who really is baseball's
all-time home run king
hell there's even an entire book
dedicated to keeping track of our most
insane achievements
but unfortunately for us
our commander-in-chief keeps breaking
records
just not the ones we want
after setting a new high with the number
of illegal aliens crossing the border
biden has done himself one better with
the price of gas skyrocketing to its
highest level
ever
a gallon of gas
costing now 417. go ahead joe take a bow
and things aren't getting better any
time soon
today i'm announcing the united states
is targeting the main artery of russia's
economy
we're banning all imports of russian oil
and gas and energy
this is a step that we're taking to
inflict further pain on putin
but there will be cost as well here in
the united states i said i would level
with the american people from the
beginning
and when i first spoke to this i said
defending freedom is going to cost it's
going to cost us as well you're damn
right it's going to cost us
if you only ban russian oil and don't
pump american
biden promised the american people he
wouldn't raise taxes on anyone making
under 400 g's but if the cost of your
everyday life surges
thanks to inflation and this gas price
spike
that's a tax hike on everybody
energy consultants are already saying
the increased fuel costs you're ready
are going to cost the average american
household
2 000
more for gasoline this year 2 000 more
this isn't just an energy crisis we're
up against it's an economic crisis too
banning russian oil and not replacing it
with a fuel from another source like
what we're doing right here isn't a plan
well unless your plan is to drive up oil
prices
if that's the case you're doing a great
job joe and maybe that is the plan it
made us to accelerate the transition of
clean energy loosening environmental
regulations or pulling back clean energy
investment won't let me explain won't
will not lower energy prices for
families but transforming our economy to
run on electric vehicles powered by
clean energy with tax credits to help
american families winterize their homes
and use less energy that will biden
can't let a good crisis go to waste so
he used the pulpit this morning to push
his little pet projects like these
electric vehicles that you just heard
him talking about
i mean
that's less than one percent of cars on
the road are electric
but suddenly we're still supposed to
fill up the other 99 of america's
roadways with evs
that's biden's short-term solution
electric cars are pricey
and their cost is only going to surge as
supply chain issues are going to make
the price of those batteries rise
so the american people
still reeling from a pandemic recession
and fighting historic inflation we're
supposed to go out and fork over
hard-earned dollars for a new electric
car
and then install a little charging
station in the garage if you have a
garage
is biden nuts
we here at prime time wanted to know
what the people thought about these
energy policies so we did what we do and
we hit the streets
[Music]
why aren't you driving an electric car
joe biden says that's the way to go
i don't have a hundred thousand dollars
i can afford when i would i can't afford
one it takes a half hour to fill up an
electric car i don't think the
technology for full electric is quite
there i don't care for electric cars do
you plan on buying an electric car
no time soon absolutely not not right
now no
no not at this time if there's more like
electric ports or charged cars i won't
be able to afford electric car because
i'll be out of money buying gas
joe biden says you're polluting if you
don't drive an electric car what do you
have to say how am i gonna work he needs
to keep in mind he's been rich forever
like a lot of people can't just oh no
yeah i'm just gonna switch to a tesla he
better focus to the gas price not about
the pollution if he's going to support
us and um
basically give us some electric cars i
don't see why not but yeah ain't giving
nobody a car it's pretty accepted that
we all pollute as part of our lives
everybody else is polluted you're
polluting if you do a lot of things i
don't really care what biden says to be
honest joe biden doesn't know what he's
doing and what he's doing to this
country f joe biden
[Music]
not only are gas prices on the rise they
are now the most expensive they've ever
been in u.s history
how is it affecting you it's killing me
that number depresses me dude it's
putting a strain i have to consider like
less shopping i take the train more i
might charge people to get in my car
i don't drive more than 50 miles in a
week we're making less money i make less
money a lot of bills and food and
gas everything's going up i'm not able
to afford to get gas sometimes so i have
to leave my car home parked some days i
go almost 50 out of sixes i think it's
enough to make a living
what kids no you're on jesse waters
prime time if president joe biden is
flipping the channels tonight what do
you want to tell them
um
yo help us out man what's wrong with you
man give me an electric car man do a
better job please get it together more
stimulus money please wake up i think he
better consider retirement retire retire
we want trump back
the people know who to blame even though
biden won't accept it
to joe this is all putin's fault
can't do much right now
russia's responsible
just another biden flip-flop he spent
the entire last week telling us he's
doing everything he can
to lower gas prices but now suddenly
there's nothing he can do
putin played a part for sure
but gas prices were at 277 this time
last year long before russia started
this war
so sorry joe this one's on you too
on your first day in office you killed
the pipeline and paused drilling on
federal lands you didn't think that
would have some effect on gas prices
instead biden continues to lie to our
face
about his energy policies listen
it's simply not true that my
administration or policies are holding
back domestic energy production
that's simply not true
here's what's true
a judge
just revoked the biggest federal
offshore lease in u.s history
and biden
won't appeal the ruling he won't appeal
it
so he just killed the biggest federal
energy lease of all time
joe biden
gulf of mexico
it's another record you broke joe way to
go
you see biden cares more about his far
left base than he cares about doing
what's best for the country
he's looking to help aoc instead of you
it's very alarming that many of the
people pushing to
increase
and skyrocket
either imports or production domestic
production in the short term are not
talking about what we really need to be
doing in terms of
rapid investments in solar and wind
solar and wind
instead of listening to these people
biden needs to come up with a plan to
lower energy costs now
not become the punchline of late-night
jokes
since the invasion oil prices have
skyrocketed today the average gas price
in america hit an all-time record high
of over four dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience is
worth a buck or two i'm willing to pay
four dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla of
course you do
and it's not just the left all america's
enemies are laughing at us as we try to
turn for him to our energy needs
biden is going had in hand
begging kings and dictators in saudi
arabia and venezuela
and possibly even the mueller's in iran
to pump more oil he wants to pay blood
money to these countries for their fuel
while they turn around and use the cash
to continue to terrorize us and their
own people
well
if they take his call
there's a new report
in the wall street journal tonight
claiming biden got stiffed by the saudis
joe biden called
and the crown prince
refused to pick up the phone
didn't take the call from the president
of the united states
so much for being the most powerful man
in the world
and for the whole climate change crowd
the oil that we make here in the u.s is
produced cleaner than any place on earth
so biden's plan is to buy dirtier oil
while making our enemies rich boy is
that stupid
but here's a novel idea mr president how
about we use more of our own oil here
rather than ask bad guys to throw us a
bone and if you're open to suggestions
we have a few
for starters
how about we repeal the gas tax
even members of your own party are
pushing it
we need to suspend the gas tax
18.4 cents a gallon but it will help
reduce
the inflationary pressures that are
causing rising
gas prices at the pump
and americans should be angry
i never thought i'd say this but listen
to richard blumenthal
and don't stop there how about you cut
the ethanol blending mandate
that actually causes more pollution they
just discovered
and while we're at it let's open alaska
for business
alaska has billions of barrels of oil
ready to be pulled out of the ground
it's time to restore the suspended
leases on the arctic national wildlife
refuge
there's 600 000 square miles of alaska
with most of it fertile drilling land
look at that
this is how we restore american energy
independence we become self-sufficient
on oil and gas and then we can sell it
to our allies who need it in europe
why do we keep pouring money into the
pockets of our enemies let's protect
ourselves
by fueling ourselves hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else